I feel really sorry for the people who
have had to endure months of coming
forward with the allegations against
Dominic Robb and then Rob resigning in
the way that he has this morning which
is incredibly defiant for a resignation
accepting the findings on the report and
you know for the Prime Minister say he's
incredibly sad well I'm incredibly sad
that the Prime Minister can't take the
action that was needed to protect civil
servants that are trying to go about
their day and it makes everybody feel
like you know the prime minister is weak
and doesn't see bullying in the
workplace as seriously saw this with the
previous prime minister who allowed um
one of the cabinet ministers to bully
someone they were found to have breached
the ministerial coal for bullying and
was allowed to continue in their job
quite different though isn't it he
received the report yesterday and by
this morning there is a resignation from
Dominic Robb so you could say he has
acted quickly and decisively well I
would argue that's not the case because
of course prime minister knew about the
allegations against Dominic rub before
he appointed into cabinet we've had
three there were allegations though
weren't there and they could have been
investigated and that could have been
dealt with before you appoint someone
into a significant senior position and
now we see even now with the resignation
this Defiance this lack of
self-awareness about what he's actually
done you know the the threshold for
bullying well if you've been found
bullying that's bullying there's no
there's no threshold for bullying you
know it's completely unacceptable to
frame it in that way and if I was one of
those victims this morning who cannot
speak out because of the process I would
be feeling absolutely devastated and it
sends the wrong message for the rest of
the civil servants who have to have
confidence that they can raise concerns
and can work in the interests of our
country and if you've got a prime
minister who's too weak to deal with
these issues then for me that will lead
to risks around governance around being
able to raise issue use and to come
forward with the what's best and what's
in the interests of the Civil Service
and these people know their job they
know it's you know it's not a question
of oh is your interpretation these
people are senior civil servants they
know their job that they're carrying out
and I think it's just completely wrong
that a Dominic Brad thinks he can frame
it in this way and that the prime
minister is saying I'm really sad you're
leaving well you shouldn't have
appointed him in the first place we
understand that that report has now been
published as soon as we're able to bring
you details of it we will get some coats
to be providing some analysis of it um
now he was effectively your counterpart
you faced off against against him many
times
um what was your sense of the man and of
his behavior I mean for me he was my
political opponent it was my political
peer so you know the relationship the
Power Balance there is different to if
you're working you know if you work for
me if you work for a senior uh Minister
like the Deputy Prime Minister then
there's a power imbalance immediately
there so you have to have self-awareness
about relationships and conduct in the
workplace myself and Dominic are
politicians and we robustly go at each
other at the dispatch box and that's
different but when you're taking advice
when you're working with civil servants
that is a different relationship and you
have to be aware as a leader about the
conduct that you put you know you bring
out in the office because you set the
culture and for all of those people to
come forward not one not two many people
to come forward notwithstanding what
happened previously where a civil
servant came forward and lost their job
after had been found that they've been
bullied it must have took significant
bravery for them to come forward and
therefore I don't think this is an
interpretation of somebody's conducting
an office this is clear that those
people felt there was bullying and the
fact that Dominic Rabb has resigned
tells me even in his Defiance that he
knows there's something there
your read of this Dominic Robb did say
that if he was found of bullying he
would resign do you get the sense that
he willingly tended that resignation or
did the Prime Minister Force his hand I
don't get the sense that the prime
minister or Dominic Rabb understand the
seriousness of that report and the
findings within it there seems to be a
sheer lack of self-awareness around the
intent the a senior level should have
known that your actions would have been
perceived in that way and how that
affected people and there was no apology
it's it's like backslapping oh you did a
good job not sorry well it was a oh I've
done a great job terrible the process
was horrible to me in dominant rabbs
um and Rishi sunax responds was not your
conduct fell below standards this is
terrible we've got to have the highest
standards it was you've done a great job
which by the way I'd argue that's not
the case in justice but it was lit
actually look at all these wonderful
things you've done thank you I'm really
sad you're leaving that report is very
clear that the Deputy Prime Minister of
this country bullied and intimidated
people in their workplace if they were
if you were the victims of that bullying
today you would be feeling that even
though Dominic Rabb has resigned that
there is no
um awareness and no acknowledgment of
what's happened or ability to put it
right just over 24 hours later he's gone
I imagine he possibly wasn't even in the
office today which may be a relief to
the some of the civil servants
um that were working for him action has
been taken well he's gone quickly and
the ministerial code has changed he
didn't have to be sacked did he could
have been sanctioned in a different way
so you could argue that this is Rishi
sinak
um bringing to Bear exactly what he
pledged on the steps of Downing Street
integrity and accountability what it
looks like to me is that they've tried
to get ahead of the report being
published because when you hear what Sam
coax was reading out in that report
that's pretty damning so his Dominic's
resignation came choreographed with
Rishi Suna act with no acknowledgment of
what's happened here just uh oh you've
done a really great job and all the
process isn't isn't quite right without
the acknowledgment actually of the
substantive issues within that report so
it's almost like trying to damage
limitate what's happened here I don't
see um Dominic rabb's resignation as
having Integrity he's not fought about
his actions he's not acknowledged what
he's done in his resignation and I don't
see the prime ministers acknowledgment
of the resignation as doing any justice
to those people that have faced bullying
and recognizing what's happened here and
what he's enabled because of course he
knew about these allegations before he
appointed him and even now with that
report I don't think the prime
minister's responded to this in a way
that you would expect a leader to
respond when that level of misconduct
has happened in a senior
um Dominic Raab in his op-ed in the
telegraph
um writes about uh how he feels that the
process has been unfair normal rules
disapplied he says that many of these
complaints should have been timed out
um because of the three-month time limit
for bringing bullying claims and then
says that they were then submitted in a
coordinated way what is your response to
that have you ever had a sense with
civil civil servants that those kind of
situations no can arise if I mean first
of all first of all viciously not
brought Dominic Rabb back into cabinet
and that's where the trigger was for
many people who had felt relief that he
wasn't there that that wasn't going to
be the case it's pretty clear that as
soon as he was brought back into cabinet
these people were frightened that he was
going to be back in the workplace and
raised it I don't think that's a problem
with that I think if you look at the
context to which these people came
forward as well as I said before the
former prime minister allowed a Cabinet
member to bully a senior civil servant
and the cabinet member kept their job
and the civil servant had to leave even
though they were the ones that were
found to have been bullied so for civil
servants under that context to bring
forward these allegations I would say
this is not a question of coordination
it must have been incredibly Brave of
them and very scary for them to bring
those allegations to the fore in the
context but they obviously believed what
Rishi sunak said and that he wanted to
drive forward as prime minister with
these integrity and with these values
and we've seen actually that hasn't been
the case and I think his letter to
Dominic rabbit is absolutely disgusting
and doesn't acknowledge the seriousness
of what's happened